[Music]
don't you wish to see the cinematics of
a lot of your favorite games being
turned into live action movies and
what's more desirable the creatures and
monsters of those games being seen in
the big screens so here in this video we
will be showcasing our pick of the
various gaming monsters that should be
in movies so subscribe if you haven't
already and now let's get down with this
list
number one the zerg firstly the coolest
monsters from games that should be in
movies or at least in tv shows are the
zerg from the starcraft games
the xerx swarm is a terrifying and
ruthless amalgamation of biologically
advanced arthropodal aliens dedicated to
the pursuit of genetic perfection the
zerg relentlessly hunt down and
assimilate advanced species across the
galaxy incorporating useful genetic code
into their own
they are named the swarm for their
ability to rapidly create strains and
the relentless assaults they employ by
overwhelming numbers to overwhelm their
foes
imagine a movie based on the starcraft
universe and set in space of course
it'll be a horror sci-fi but what a show
it will be if the protoss plays a
reclusive role and the gerunds being the
ones facing a sudden cosmic horror
threat with the hidden subplot that
their leader is the one behind it all
imagine seeing the hydrolyst the
zerglings and the ultralisk and also the
queen of blades in live action number
two the reapers another sci-fi movie
that would be a blockbuster hit is if it
is based on the game mass effect or at
least an adaptation of it it could go
for a tv show as well but it would be
hella expensive but with the millions of
fans of the game as well as millions of
others
sci-fi nerds around the world the
reapers of mass effect would indeed have
a mass effect on the grass revenue of
that movie the monsters called the
reapers would be the prime antagonist
and this would be kind of a survival
type of movie that would immediately
follow
the reaper's arrival and apocalypse
after their arrival and it could be an
action movie as well the reapers also
known as the old machines by the get an
ancient race of aliens uh well the
reapers are also an ancient race of
gigantic living spaceships initially
thought to be a myth the reapers
hibernate in dark space between galaxies
for thousands of years and then return
to the galaxy every few millennia to
destroy all the milky way's most
advanced civilizations
or at least that would be the prelude to
the movie
number three deathwing well the 2016
movie
warcraft didn't actually make quite a
dent on the movie screens maybe it was
the lack of connection of the plots or
the unrealistic and up in the cloud
storytelling and action scenes but what
could save that particular universe in
the cinemas is if there is another flick
about the end of that world coming from
a cataclysm
yes i'm talking about the dreaded death
wing coming to life with excellent cgi
the likes and the level of smoke but
this monster wouldn't be the center of
the storyline but would still be a big
part of it i know this would be
deathwing and a burning legion being
behind the center of the apparent cause
of the end of the world and the movie
would follow a group of heroes finding a
way to prevent it or at least delay the
end imagine a gigantic dragon that is
near impossible to kill
number 4 death claws
what's another game with a fantastic
plot that can be adapted into a movie
look no further than fallout the movie
would be in a post-apocalyptic future
the prelude would start by stating that
in the 21st century a series of
conflicts break out around the globe
over dwindling resources and after years
of conflict and nuclear war occurs
the effects of that war do not fade for
the next hundreds of years and as a
consequence human society collapses the
main plot would be to secure resources
for a dying community but then new
threats emerge in the form of mutants
and a death clause
well what a death laws well the death
clause would be the obstacles that the
protagonists would have to overcome they
were
originally genetically engineered
soldiers in the first place and later
after they escaped they become the new
apex predators hard to kill and what's
more scary they are packed creatures
number 5 devilio
last year we got to see a movie
a movie adaptation of a very famous game
and that game is monster hunter well
this movie followed a group of soldiers
who were transported into another world
and a soul survivor had to face off
against a diablos a swab of nercilla and
a ruthless
which were all good monsters but what it
lacked is the most famous of them all
the t-rex of that universe the devilio
if there is another follow-up movie to
this monster flick then they need to
include that creature make it a bit
reclusive and not all revealing a sort
of a survival movie with the devilio
being the main villain and one that the
protagonists have to team up and find a
way to stop it lest it cause a lot of
destruction and deaths of course it
won't be the only one other famous
monsters like the xenogray and the narco
cougar would also have to be in that
movie
number 6 the rift worm well the gears of
war movie has been in production and
been in development in some form or
another for well over a decade now no
thanks to hollywood but now they have
some hope thanks to some successful and
high quality adaptations of many other
games in netflix this movie would have
to take place on another planet called
sarah well in that universe in that
planet a liquid called emulsion becomes
a highly valued power source and nations
fight for control of it what monster
would be seen here well it's none other
than the deadlier and way bigger version
of the sand worms of dune these are the
rift worms and they are gargantuan worm
like creatures that could grow to 10
miles in length and half a mile wide
they are worshiped as gods for another
faction of mutated subterranean humans
that are enemies of the surface dwellers
this movie could steal a few tips from
dune but then improve on another area
more screen time for giant monsters
and lastly number seven the brethren
moons
with a lot of sci-fi alien movies in
coming in the next two years why not
create one base on the game dead space
it would for sure rival the horror of
the xenomorph aliens well just on the
ground level and also bring out the
cosmic apocalyptic fear from the
brethren moons
how would humanity face off and fend off
such a threat well the bread and moon
sometimes referred to as brother moons
or blood moons are gigantic space-faring
necromorphs
kinda like dead beings that turn other
living
beings into dead beings they are
believed to be the final stage of the
necromorph species their life cycle
think about a movie that starts with a
strange object falling from the sky
and all the governments of the world
would be like what is this whoa and this
would be later revealed to be the marker
and from it strange deadly aliens would
emerge kind of like the scenes from the
movie annihilation but over time this
would represent an incoming threat from
the blood moons humanity as a whole must
unite to fight it or face the threat of
being turned into these necromorphs and
the planet earth being turned into
another brethren moon
anyway with that we come to the end of
this list of the seven gaming monsters
that should be
seen in the movie screens in live action
so do hit that like button for support
and subscribe as well to be a part of
the mind cue family but most of all
smash the bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam